nowadays the main reason most people
know mark cuban is because of shark tank
and the mavericks he's famous for making
offers with the short life spans and
pouncing on entrepreneurs whenever he
feels that something is off
i'm i'm so out i'm so out so outside
basically but yeah but that's what she
is she's a gold digger mm-hmm she's a
gold medalist she's not a gold digger
did you just call me gold digger his
bombastic personality and bloated ego
are also hard to miss despite these
quirks though mark is by far the most
reliable shark on the show following
through with 87.5 percent of the deals
he makes on-air that's nearly double all
the other sharks but when you consider
that he's worth 5 times more than the
rest of the regular sharks combined at
5.93 billion dollars it's not surprising
that he's able to be much more lenient
with his deals while mark often talks
about how he had to hustle to make it to
the top it's never made clear how
exactly he made his money so here's how
mark cuban became the only regular
billionaire on shark tank
taking a look back mark was born on july
31 1958 in pittsburgh pennsylvania to a
jewish immigrant family his father's
side were immigrants from russia and his
paternal grandfather had changed the
family name from chabinski to cuban when
he arrived at ellis island meanwhile his
mother's side were immigrants from
romania in the u.s mark's father was
making a living as an automobile
upholsterer while his mother was a
homemaker mark's family wasn't
particularly wealthy but from a very
young age mark was always trying his
best to make money in any way he could
when he was 12 for instance he sold
garbage bags door-to-door until he could
afford some expensive basketball shoes
similarly when he was 16 the pittsburgh
post gazette went on strike and mark
levered this opportunity to sell
newspaper from cleveland to pittsburgh
clearly mark was doing pretty well for
himself as a teenager but he had no
interest in just sticking around at the
same level he would grind through high
school and graduate a year early which
allowed him to enroll in the university
of pittsburgh originally mark chose this
college because he was a big fan of the
pittsburgh steelers but after just one
year he decided that it was much better
to choose college based on finances so
he would transfer over to indiana
university in bloomington because it
offered the cheapest tuition out of the
top 10 business schools mark never
ditched his entrepreneurial side though
in college he helped run a pub and
taught disco lessons but soon enough his
college days would come to an end in
1981 when he graduated with a bachelor's
in business administration and
specializing in management following
college mark would move back to
pennsylvania and secure a job at mellon
bank at the time melon bank was in the
process of switching from paper to
computers and this really showcased to
mark the potential of computers but mark
didn't stick around for long just one
year later mark decided to move to
dallas texas and picked up jobs as a
bartender and a salesman at a company
called your business software even today
mark says that if he had to start over
from scratch being a salesman during the
day and a bartender during the night is
exactly what he would do
this way he would have a stable income
from bartending and a scalable income
from selling unfortunately for mark
though he would get fired from a sales
job during his first year because one
day he was meeting with a client instead
of opening up the store
instead of looking for another job
though mark decided that it was time to
start his first company
mark's first company was a software
consulting service called micro
solutions the business was basically a
copy of mark's former employer your
business software but mark felt that he
could do it way better than them and
that's really all you need one of mark's
core business principles is that
execution is way more important than the
idea he says that everyone has a great
idea but very few people are able to
execute mark also preaches that
following your passion is one of the
great lies of life if he had followed
his passion he says that he would have
ended up as a field basketball or
baseball player
instead mark has always insisted on
following opportunity and the
opportunity with micro solutions was
that mark had already built up a client
base at his old job so he just had to
convince them to switch over and being
the hustler that he is this wasn't too
difficult
aside from building up a solid client
base including people like ross pro mark
was quick to adopt new technologies such
as remote screen sharing client server
software platforms and of course the
internet by 1990 micro solutions had
grown to 30 million revenue and this
stellar performance started to attract
some acquisition offers and that same
year mark would sell micro solutions to
compuserve for 6 million dollars which
worked out to about 2 million after
taxes for mark adjusting for inflation
we're talking about around 4.2 million
dollars which is nowhere close to being
a billionaire but mark was more than
happy with this amount you see mark was
never trying to become a billionaire he
just wanted to be financially free and
enjoy life and 4.2 million dollars was
more than enough to do just that one of
mark's first orders of business after
cashing out was spending six hundred
thousand dollars on an american airlines
unlimited pass as the name suggests this
allows mark to travel on american
airlines first class unlimited times
mark says that over the next five years
he used the pass to travel the world and
party like a madness so i bought that
lifetime pass on american airlines we'd
walk into a club and this was after i
sold my company and we just buy bottles
of cristal
for everybody apparently the long-term
cost of the ticket came out to just 12
cents per mile to put that in
perspective the average airfare cost
roughly 11.5 cents per mile so about the
same amount but mark was flying in first
class
this was clearly a terrible business
decision by american airlines and that's
probably why they discontinued the pass
but the pass is still valid for people
who already bought it and today mark is
one of 25 people who still have the pass
mark clearly had a blast of
globetrotting through the early 1990s
but it didn't take him long to jump into
yet another business
mark didn't found this next company in
fact he wasn't even looking to get
involved in another business but when
the opportunity popped up he couldn't
refuse
one of his friends from college todd
wagner introduced mark to a man named
cameron jabe cameron had started a
company called the cameron audio
networks in 1999 that specialized in
streaming sports games originally
cameron was attempting to sell handheld
satellite devices to broadcast the
sports games but in the early 1990s he
switched over to streaming over the
internet
being a massive basketball fan mark was
super interested in the idea and he
would agree to invest ten thousand
dollars in return for two percent of the
company which value the business at five
hundred thousand dollars this was
actually a rather high valuation for the
business given that they hadn't even
launched it cameron was still working on
negotiating streaming rights with
broadcasters but despite the early
nature of the business mark became
increasingly interested with the time
and he would actually offer to take over
the company cameron agreed presumably
because he didn't expect the company to
grow that fast or that big but this
would turn out to be a massive mistake
for cameron mark rebranded the company
as audionet and launched the service in
september of 1995. he would eventually
change the name once again to
broadcast.com in 1998. in the meantime
the business was growing pretty nicely
as they were able to accumulate 570 000
users within the first few years ideally
this business should have been worth a
couple million dollars maybe 10 million
at max but this was during the height of
the dot-com bubble when mark took the
company public in 1998 the stock soared
250 on the first day of trading which by
the company had 1 billion dollars
having roughly a 30 stick in the company
works net worth to jump to 300 million
dollars later on in 1999 mark would
diversify the company into video
streaming as well helping victoria's
secret livestream a fashion show that
same year yahoo would offer to purchase
the company for 5.7 billion dollars and
to mark taking the deal was a no-brainer
as it would net him roughly 1 billion
dollars today this acquisition is
regarded as one of the worst
acquisitions of all time as yahoo would
end up shutting down the service in 2002
honestly though i think the failure of
the business was mostly yahoo's fault i
mean just take a look at how big
streaming is today we have youtube
twitch netflix hulu prime video and so
much more netflix itself is worth 250
billion today so i think yahoo threw
away a massive opportunity with
broadcast.com the same could be said
about mark as well
instead of selling the company you could
have tried to navigate the company
through the dotcom crash and if you were
successful in growing it into something
like youtube he'd be worth tens of
billions today but mark preferred to
just take the one billion dollars
upfront and you can't really blame him
for that anyway after the acquisition
mark dumped all his yahoo stock within a
year which was really smart given what
was coming and with that mark was
officially a billionaire not only on
paper but in cash
mark is actually super transparent about
getting extremely lucky with
broadcast.com first of all he was super
lucky to get introduced to cameron then
he was super lucky that cameron agreed
to let mark take over the company and
finally he got super lucky that yahoo
offered to purchase the money losing
company for billions mark says that if
he started over getting to millions and
tens of millions would be no problem but
in terms of reaching a billion he'd have
to get lucky once again
anyway after the sale mark began to
splurge his newfound wealth in october
of 1999 he purchased the gulf stream jet
for 40 million over the internet which
won him a world record for making the
largest single e-commerce transaction
shortly after mark bought the dallas
mavericks for 285 million dollars in
january of 2000. mark wasn't really
trying to make an investment with the
team he really just loved basketball and
wanted to help grow a team to the top
but this has ironically turned into a
fantastic investment thanks to the team
stellar performance before mark bought
the mavericks they only won 40 of their
games but in the 10 years following his
purchase the mavericks won 69 percent of
their games and they even won the nba
finals in 2011. today the mavericks are
valued at 2.7 billion dollars which is
nearly a 10x on mark's investment mark
has also been trying to get into the
show business for quite some time and
though shark tank is extremely
successful today the same cannot be said
about mark's initial endeavors one of
mark's first attempts at starting a tv
show was in 2004 when he produced a show
called the benefactor the show was kind
of like the apprentice 16 contestants
would compete in various challenges to
try to win 1 million dollars and mark
would judge their performance throughout
the show but unfortunately ratings were
so bad that the series was cancelled
before the first season was fully aired
around the same time mark also bought
magnolia pictures and the landmark
cinema and though these have been good
investments they're nothing spectacular
something spectacular was just around
the corner though
mark first appeared as a guest shark in
2011 and it didn't take long for him to
become a regular shark ratings for the
show have ballooned ever since he joined
the team and he's one of the most
sought-after sharks by entrepreneurs
within the first and seasons of shark
tank mark made over 100 deals on air and
given that he has the highest closing
rate we can assume that most of these
went through in terms of money invested
as of 2015 mark had invested a total of
19.85 million dollars on air and this
figure is probably closer to 40 million
today which is the highest on the show
in terms of percent of net worth
invested though mark is the lowest as he
hasn't even invested one percent of his
net worth because he's just too big of a
baller anyway mark is notorious for
making sure lifespan offers and he loves
to hate on supplement companies but at
the end of the day mark always has the
entrepreneur's backs
originally shark tank entrepreneurs were
forced to either give the production
company two percent of their profits or
five percent equity in the company if
they want to appear on the show honestly
this is a pretty fair deal given that
sales usually explode after shark tank
airing but mark felt that the production
company was already making more than
enough money and that they didn't need
to eat into entrepreneurs businesses so
he threatened to leave the show if the
company didn't drop the shark tank tax
and given how important mark is to the
show the company agreed and that's how
mark cuban went from a teenage boy
selling garbage bags to being everyone's
favorite billionaire on shark tank do
you guys think mark just got lucky with
broadcast.com comment that down below
also drop a like if you wish that you
were as lucky as mark and of course
consider joining our discord community
to suggest future video ideas and
continue to subscribe and see more
questions logically answered but until
then i'm hari and i'll see you guys on
the next one